all right so we want to do something a
little different here you know I'm
always interviewing people so a lot of
times their opinions get heard more than
mine which I actually like because I
like listening to people and I like just
being part of the conversation but a lot
of times especially on Twitter you guys
are asking me what I think about this or
that or whatever the hot-button issue is
of the day and I do try to get as much
of that stuff out there but we thought
we'd take a bunch of those stuff just
the meat that everybody's talking about
all the time and make kind of short
videos letting you know what I think
about these things and what I think
about these things in many cases has
evolved will continue to evolve I don't
profess to be an expert in any specific
one of these but I can tell you what I
think about them as we do this right now
in December of 2015 so gun control I
thought would be a good one to start
with because I don't know that there's
anything that makes people crazier than
gun control so look basically I believe
in the Second Amendment I believe that
people should have the right to bear
arms that doesn't mean necessarily that
you should have the capacity to kill and
shoot hundreds of people within seconds
and some of these crazy weapons now look
when the when the framers of the
Constitution and the Bill of Rights put
this stuff in it was because they had a
healthy distrust of government after
they left England then they didn't want
to live under a king right I have a lot
of that healthy distrust of government I
think government is epically
dysfunctional does not operate properly
I don't trust our politicians at all I
think that's clear but the idea that
we're gonna have these militias that are
wanting to overtake the government is
kind of crazy so we have to figure out
some sensible gun control now of course
this is impossible because the NRA
basically makes it impossible and they
are an incredibly powerful lobby but it
also has to come from us and we do have
to realize that not you know a lot of
times people on the right will frame
this as this is a slippery slope if you
let them take our machine gun next thing
you know they're gonna take the shotgun
it's not I don't think it's as slippery
as that but again I do believe that
people should be allowed to have guns I
also think that you know as I say often
on the show that two things can be true
at the same time we do have a gun
problem right it is too easy to get
these things but also at the same time
we
really of a mental health problem right
because if you go out if you get a gun
whether you get it illegally legally how
are you take it from your parents
whatever you do you don't go out and
shoot people in a mall or at a college
or at a holiday party unless you are
mentally unhealthy right unless you're
mentally unstable so two things can be
true at the same time access is too much
and the mental health issue that we have
look and if you don't think there's a
mental health issue and I know
unfortunately we don't talk about it on
TV because why yeah because they are
putting up the commercials for
everything every other commercial on
cable news is for you know to get off
cigarettes but if you take that it's
gonna make you poop and if you have
restless leg syndrome
it might make you suicidal and what and
you know you have a depression cloud
following you so take another
antidepressant and all these things make
us crazy so we're a crazy society then
then we medicate ourselves too and in
many many many of these shooting cases
we find out that these people are on
these medications so yeah I'm not look I
am I'm trying not to be an absolutist
here but that being said all of that
being said yeah I do for your zombie
invasion so would I like to have a gun
yeah because I may not have Daryl with a
crossbow so I would like to have access
to guns